hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the mannequin now this
seems like a game straight out of my
nightmares because I hate mannequins I
always have they aren't really played up
much in horror games these days but this
one seems like it might just be there
this game has not yet been rated it is
intended for persons aged 16 or over and
then when younger should seek permission
well I have a mental age of seven so I
think I'll I think I'll be okay
put them on now alright well I'll use a
mouse and keyboard not some controller
scrub there the mannequin de stupid keys
one of these has to be the right one aha
Lisa has a very deep voice too so you
know hey dad it's me I'm at the house
now just got inside whoa
that looks cool thanks for doing at
least I really appreciate no problem you
still at the funeral home yeah dotting
the eyes and crossing the t's he knows
how it is
yeah that's understandable it's so dark
in here
musty is hell - Oh gross just got a face
full of spiderwebs
yeah I did I didn't see that yeah watch
out for those I'd imagine the place is a
complete state isn't it no one's been
there in ages yeah just a bit how long
has it been empty well my mom had it in
58 but I don't think she ever lived in
it she refused to sell it never did say
why now she passed it's ended up with us
so it's been empty ever since must be
worth a fortune though surely a house of
this size in the heart of London well
that's why you're here I'll have to tidy
up the place before we can get it really
at this rate I'll be the one doing most
of the cleaning ooh
why why what bloody hell no service why
why why why why my flashlight no work in
there that this is a really weird
flashlight did no go distant OH
ah face full of cobweb there we go well
this place is in a complete state what
an absolute unit of a place okay yeah no
cell service in the heart of London yeah
I wonder what that's all about that's
bizarre I love the rain and I love the
style of this place it was pretty cool
also pretty terrifying
flick
if you [ __ ] flip it like do nothing
I'm flicking it do nothing I flicked you
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you I'm flicking
I'm [ __ ] and I'm blacking I'm not
looking as hard as I can flock okay
anyway that don't work
oddly enough don't work who'da thunk old
it wouldn't work
alright well I don't like that there's
big old sheets over everything that
looks like a grandfather clock but it
could be a very tall zombie I'm not
gonna go down you know I'm just no you
know going down would probably be a bad
idea and so I'm I'm gonna go now I'm
gonna go down because I'm a big brave oh
thank goodness there are these
incredibly strong box it's blocking my
bath oh good good I can't go that way
alright well oh it's lovely up here oh
this is just delightful oh that is just
goddamn beautiful oh that is just a
slice of something special
okay this is less slicing of something
special I'm looking and I'm vlogging
this flicky flack you don't work either
oh okay bloody ell this house really
needs some TLC lookin Lema flocking just
looking omma flocking i think it's fine
oddly enough I think that everything is
fine weirdly against all of my instincts
everything seems to be fine so I'm gonna
let my guard down and continue on okay
that's a weird thing doesn't even have a
doorknob on it okay ooh this is pretty
well that's that's lovely
oh that's lovely oh that's lovely that
is louver Lee man this is huge
this would be worth a fortune it's like
five storey
oh it's a dark room keep shut don't like
how quickly that one opened okay fire
place looks nice god it's hate
everything about this is so calm it's
too calm
alright who's in there hey who's in
there oh come on I just want it with a
flick the light switch a little bit okay
fine then see ya going upstairs again
top floor yeah it is five stories geez
okay
you know what I think I'm good I think
I'm good you know oh you know what you
know what I've thought about it
flaky flaky flaky flaky I've got
flicking no more itching okay
um very I don't like the arms on that
thing okay I'm just looking anywhere
else but the mannequin okay and then I'm
gonna look straight into the mannequins
but um all right well you know you're
you're good over there okay
hey how you doing what a sad looking
mannequin yeah kind of feel sorry for it
being left here broken and abandoned
yeah Oh sad yeah sad is the word I'd use
I wonder if these parts on the floor
belong to it oh who cares don't do what
I think I'm about to do
Oh God pick up it's not do that let's
let's not do that
examine pick up nope you know I'm good
Oh how about we just go out the front
door that seems like a good idea all
right okay
oh gosh of this in your standup here you
come on your Blanc clunk oh I'll pick it
up a little uncle oh yeah this is a good
idea this is what we in the business
call a good idea
oh let's we'll pick you up hose and
shove you right in there Wow don't you
look creepy
yeah not sad anymore very creepy well
you're glad I did that I'm a back away
slowly I'm backing away I'm backing away
rails off
I'm gonna pretend like that wasn't the
door slamming behind me because I'm
backing away real slow damn it's locked
okay where'd the mannequin go well you
know I don't know that music coming from
downstairs Oh
[Music]
yep alright smooth jazz
I like it good very London
[Music]
what a bob wow this place is lovely
uh-huh okay
this film is being ruined but I probably
need that okay I don't have any comments
and why this is super flaky Mulliken and
I'm a flacon no more flocking no more
engine tragedy on London terrace woods
night favorite a family was murdered in
this house oh my god they never found
the little girl
well that's bizarre and all fixed all
better okay
[Music]
huh all right what did grandma do in
this place I'm afflicted I flicked okay
all right hey hello hello that still
doesn't work
I guess I go downstairs oh that's nice
oh that's real nice hey you come here Oh
gasp oh my name is uh whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa gate all right
that's bizarre okay oh okay we're just
gonna ignore it there's nothing to be
done here so why hold okay all right you
know I'll just move it on
ain't nothing weird in there oh this
room isn't some clean I'm guessing maybe
I maybe I didn't do everything I needed
to do oh oh oh oh horrible horrible
horrible horrible horrible or maybe I
could just go can I just go can I go
someone took the mail I can't go cuz
there's not really a knob on this door
well that's bizarre
then granny would have told me about
that hello
this stuff wasn't here earlier that's
your biggest concern about this this
can't be the same house Shirley well I
mean what's weirder you somehow
magically got transported to another one
crouch I'm a crouching I'm a turnin whoa
oh wow okay well I'm a turnin turnin it
doesn't seem to be nothing but uh
alright I'm gonna get up now
okay can I drink some hello then
hello
[Music]
nice doll looks like the mannequin and
the bathtub upstairs it's too quiet I
don't like I just don't okay Wow nice
very nice-nice face I like it actually I
hate it but that's okay okay well
nothing crazy in here can I put this
back on there we go everything's good in
the world okay let's go up let's go down
let's go downstairs let's see what the
hell could be downstairs if it is hell
that's gonna be a weird surprise Oh
[Music]
oh I gotta admit you know why oh did you
do this what do you want from me oh just
gone no working no working no not
working okay well I guess I'll go back
up B I'll go off B I can't flick no more
well hoping it is railing oh the front
door oh it seems uh - suspicious but I'm
gonna go for it Yahoo freedom hey why
would you do that
hey you got some questions
oh great here we are
in here oh okay this is so cool it's
such a good hi it's daddy are you gonna
help us move in or not
whoa Jesus he's too busy playing with a
camera come to Linton used to like to
bring in what da [ __ ] what the [ __ ] all
right just take a photo my two favorite
girls
oh I'm boarded in now
Yahoo I'll just take this a roll of film
what is going on in this place
all right open maybe I can develop in
this dark room upstairs yeah that's a
good idea yeah it's good idea you
staying here longer not just crash one
of these windows and go through it now
go the dark room I'll go to the dark
room oh yeah I'll go to the dark room
you know I love the dark room about dark
it is in the dark room I love how the
feeling of death just closes in all
around me in the dark room all right
let's go the dark remove a big propane -
maybe I blow huh huh well now it's dark
but I can use the red I need to turn off
my flashlight in the dark room but okay
canister protector wait photo paper
chemical tray remove finish photo
okay canister projector you got it
where's the projector okay oh here we go
okay please you got it that's not how
that would work but okay you know it's
fine it's fine it's fine we're gonna
okay examine pick up you got it okay
into chemical tray I put it in there oh
yeah that's good okay wait
well I got that that's nice
that's real nice I saw that's good I'm
glad I have this now what do I do
anybody want a picture sorry I got a
picture hello anybody uh
ah this so part of the cleaning process
this this this house was possessed by an
OCD maid and I've just got to clean it
[Music]
hi
we are Lady Sophie welcome to our
wonderful home please do not put your
feet on our chairs and do not remember
to curtsy whenever you see us do
remember I do declare Lady Sophie this
really is a most marvelous house how
kind of you to have me over for high tea
what a fine dress that is so glamorous I
dare say it was created by a dressmaker
of impeccable taste and talent okay
weird but oh that's gone now oh my neck
you keep breaking it oh that's it okay
so if what I'm to gather from that is
correct then the story is the little
girl is the only one that wasn't killed
in this murder and then they take over
these bodies of this mannequin and live
forever in a dream world was this just a
demo though it was so cool though it was
so cool that was really really really
well done I loved it I loved the pacing
of it I loved the artistic styling of it
everything was a little cartoony and
that was good because it liked it gave
this consistent style it is a demo this
was just a demo but this is good it's
good it's good stuff good stuff right
here well done well made good ambience
good fear like a dog feel it dripping
off the walls that was great but that
was dad that's the end of the game so
thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know what you thought down in the
comments if you got other horror games
that you want me to play put them down
in the comments below as well
and if you want to help support the
channel click that join button you get a
lot of special perks for it and thanks
again for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
but I
[Music]